uh but under current law to be able to
put this
this splint on somebody you need to be a
licensed ems provider
and many of my members are not licensed
ems providers some are
uh but many many are not and
this law will make it legal for them to
put this on
uh they are all anybody that would
would do that would be trained
majority of our we we do about 30
missions a year
we can be three four five miles away
from
the road and
it takes about 20 people to carry
somebody out that distance so the sooner
we can get that
on the better fish and game conservation
officers are
are exempt from this
the license requirement
and this many times we are first on the
scene
typically
you know at least 75 80 percent of the
rescuers are are volunteers uh from a
search and rescue team and this will
just correct
i i think uh maybe an oversight that
will allow search and rescue members win
uh working on a on a mission activated
by fish and game uh to provide
minimal uh
first aid uh non-invasive
but would allow allow us to do that
without being in conflict with the ems
law
happy to answer any questions thank you
chief any questions for the chief
seeing none thank you very much chief
thank you
next up is colonel jordan
chief enforcement officer for fish and
game
um
that yeah that would be better should i
start over
uh i apologize for that so this is uh
this has been a an issue in the past for
us so this law would just clean that up
and it would make it much easier for
them to do their job
i will tell you without the help of
these volunteer groups i think i've said
this many times here we wouldn't be
doing search and rescue and the pemi
team is is one of our number one teams
that helps us so
those carryouts would require every
officer i have in the state on duty to
cover so they would be nobody available
to do anything else so i want to any
chance we get to help these volunteer
groups uh is it's in our best interest
the state's best interest to do that
that's all i have thanks chief questions
for the chief
representative howard
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question is there a limit to
what medical
service they can provide
there is i think the the law states now
the current law starts talking about
invasive medical procedures so if you
were if you were conducting um you know
most of our emergency services are
that are done on a trail in wilderness
are
splinting bandaging
those kinds of types of injuries and
you'd be okay to do that if we were to
start
providing medical treatment meds or
doing any kind of invasive surgery type
operations you couldn't do that and we
wouldn't do that on a trail anyway okay
thank you yep
any other questions for the colonel
colonel so we're talking about um
so non-philanthropy i'm not going to say
non-certified some person might be
certified in first aid or other
provisions but non-licensed
people who would potentially providing
first aid type of services bandages that
kind of thing splints and and and some
license there would be some that are
licensed to do that but yes that would
be allowing the law requires them to be
licensed to do this in their townships
and and it doesn't expand to when folks
come down to into franconia if they
don't have a license for that so this
would allow them to do that
and does this i'm sorry follow-up so
this and this would extend to
just also non-fire department that you
might have a relationship with that are
that a search and rescue team so putting
my hat on as the civil air patrol
squadron commander right should they
have search and rescue teams that help
for downed aircraft and other reasons
that are also at the call of fish and
games so if they
if they were to go out and help you in a
search and they found it found the
subject and they could apply basic first
aid measures yes and without worrying
about liability yeah so that yeah so
just to clear up a little confused the
chief wears many hats behind me here
because he's a he's a
very dedicated public servant but most
of his pemmy team are not fire
departments they're they're
they're a variety of people a lot of
medical people uh some that are
non-medical um so yes that would be
correct
thank you thank you representative
harvey so um
at times do you use just members of the
public to help in searches and so forth
i do but we limit that
uh i call these my i refer to these
folks as my professional volunteers
that's really who i rely on i would not
ask
unless it was a dire emergency i would
not ask a common citizen to to perform
any kind of medical procedure i would
want one of these folks on board so
follow up please
so this would not include the those just
general members of the public that that
you have to use on a extremely i would
say no i would say that this would only
this would only apply to those search
and rescue team members okay thank you
any further questions
seeing none thank you sir
so anybody else would like to testify on
senate bill 260.
seeing none
quick a quick straw poll um kind of
getting a sense of where we want to go
on the executive on this um
is there any but let me put it this way
who would be in favor of ought to pass
as written and presented
right now
so anybody a post
okay
so i'm going to close the public hearing
on senate bill 260
and i will open the executive session on
senate bill 260 and i look to
representative smith for a motion
thank you mr chairman i'll make a motion
otp senate bill 260.
and the second invite representative
harvey
one second because we don't have a clerk
i'm playing chairman clerk
and clerk
is there any further discussion on
senate bill 260.
representative close
uh just to make you aware we've had this
bill before us i believe the colonel is
testified before in this bill
bill like it
and
the problem wasn't the committee we
passed it like 20 i believe it was 21 to
nothing but when they got the finance
that's where we got into trouble and
that's where we shot down
so i just want to make you aware of that
well the good news this doesn't have an
fn on the end of it so i don't think
it's going to finance
all right are we ready for the vote
give me one second and turn put this
other hat on
um
representative khan yes
representative close
representative howard
representative craig
is not here
representative love
representative wolf
represent
kittridge
yes
representative allard
represent smith
yes
representative harvey
represent query
yes
representative espanita
well oh i'm sorry represent max miller
representative gallagher
yes
represent kenny isn't here
represent horgan
yes
represent sherlock yes
and the chair votes yes so anybody i
missed
no
on a vote 15-0
um the motion about a pass
carries and i
put it on consent unless there's an
objection
seeing no objection will be on consent
and just like that we're done ladies and
gentlemen until 10 30. and we'll be back
at 10 30. um we'll close the executive
session we'll be back at 10 30 where
we'll take up the two bills that are uh
under interim study and hope hopefully
knock them out with as much efficiency
so thank you
uh so wait so for those of us who are
substituting we're substituting for the
first hearing do we need to be back for
that or is that a separate thing talk to
your minority leader ragging member and
she'll give you the where to go
okay
and just like that that one's done
what
yeah just do uh
something real if you if you don't do it
i'll do it don't worry about it it's not
that hard
yep
smith made the motion second motion
about to pass it was seconded by harvey
the bills from interim studies
well that's that's what i thought we
don't have to come back anymore okay
um i'll give you a heads up on on
you know what i'm thinking this is going
to go is uh
i'm guessing on the search mark that
we're just going to not recommend
i think that's going to be
literally just put the rules in place
last month right
and i would agree with both of those um
search and rescue i just think we need
more than just this afternoon
to talk about that not such a rescue
yeah
yeah i think we'll be done i think the
you know colonel jordan's already agreed
to work with anybody else in the future
that might want to clean up the existing
language which doesn't actually have
anything to do with the bill itself just
to do with that 207 language to a six
language
and so
he's free to do that on his own any
member's free to pick up the ball and go
15 minutes each bill and we're done i
think we've all heard the public
password we already recommend
just just so
presently smith 15 to zero
schmidt over here
recommendation is i'm sorry
so no this is
so we're going to call a work session of
the fish and game committee into order
we have two bills that we held over
for interim study
one bill is uh house bill 1091 relative
the search warrant for individuals
engaged in fish and game activities and
the second one was
house bill 1201 fn which was relative
the bear damage
i'm gonna um
take up we'll take up first um
house bill 1091
and just to quick summarize at least my
version of the summary of what what we
talked about on this bill and what we
heard in testimony was this was the
difference between the i was it 207 or
206 colonel jordan i was
206. the 206 conservation officer
language and the full-blown peace
police powers language under 207 fish
and game officers can have a standard of
reasonable suspicion in order to do
certain searches whereas under the 594
language sits full blown police officer
is its probable cause standard
for searches
the testimony we heard was that there
have been three cases brought to the
supreme court all of which have been
found in favor of the reasonable
suspicion standard at this point
that being said colonel jordan did i'll
paraphrase what he said if he can get
his hands around the neck of the person
who wrote the 206 statute he'd be happy
to
throttle them
and so he's willing to work with any
member that might want to go forward
with language around that 207 to clean
up that the 206 statute to clean that up
but this bill isn't wasn't it um
remember we we deal with
what's actually the written words on the
page and not the concepts of things and
so the written words on this page were
not in such a way that we wanted to pass
it um i just in respect to colonel
jordan and that comment about working
with somebody on the 206 language i
wanted the interim study which i thought
was the appropriate motion so my
inclination on this bill again because
we deal with the words written on the
page and not the concepts is that
this should not be recommended for
future legislation but i'll open it up
for further discussion and if anybody
wants to ask colonel jordan questions or
anybody who wants to testify in the
audience so why that might be a bad idea
happy to listen to it but is there any
further comment from the committee
um on house bill 1091
relative search warrants
representative harvey
um i i would be happy to take your
recommendation because um colonel jordan
is really the the expert and
although there may be problems it does
seem like it's a problem that
if we try to very quickly in the next
you know 15 30 minutes to fix we could
come up with something that's worse and
i think his offer to work with somebody
and come up with a better bill is a good
offer so i would be very much in favor
of your
recommendation of um not
so just to be clear our only committee
recommendations are either recommend it
for future legislation or not recommend
it for future legislation not to redraft
language or consider amendments or
anything else it's about the language
that's in the bill and whether we think
this bill should move forward for future
legislation for someone else to take a
look at it again
um so i just want to be clear on that
we're not going to be drafting any
language strictly whether or not the
current law the current bill is written
we recommend for future or not so just
to make sure we're clear on what the
motions are thank you
oregon go ahead
i believe this might have been heard
today one of the days i was substituting
and i was struck by the fact that um
you know the
second amendment group came out and
forced to testify against it but we
didn't get any input against it from the
actual sportsman communities it wasn't
anybody who was
actually engaged in
hunting or trapping or fishing that was
opposed to it which was sort of uh
interesting some
um it was
probably another sign in my mind that uh
that it's best that it's like best not
to try to like best to wait till next
year to try to do anything with this
idea of that
okay colonel jordan did you want to add
anything did i summarize okay
thank you any further comments from
committee members
representative close thank you mr
chairman
being a police officer and making many
arrests
i've got a lot of search warrants i got
two of the biggest ones ever the state
ever had on probable cause
i think
what we have here is
some of the old type
game ones that used to do certain things
uh going to bob houses and you know you
hear all kinds of stories about this and
that
and it's not that way today today we
have a ceo that's well-educated
uh the ceos are well run they have
super very good supervisors i've seen a
lot of them i've dealt with a lot of
them
i fish a lot i hunt a lot i'm everywhere
over the state
and i've been checked more than probably
30 40 times by ceos and everyone has
been polite everyone has been courteous
i have a bob house of cattle landing
they always knock on the door before
they come in
i've never had a problem with ceo
they've asked to come in
and what you want to do is be careful
because a lot of the
people
especially the police officer i want to
get into your trunk
i'll be real nice and polite to you you
know would you let me look in there you
know then all of a sudden i find a pound
of marijuana in there then all things
have changed
but when you
go and
start looking for search warrants you're
opening up a whole bucket of worms
if i have to get a search warrant i'll
guarantee you one thing you're going to
jail if i find something i'm going to
impound your car i'm going to take your
gun i'm going to take your fishing rod
i'm going to take your boat
if i have to do all the typing and make
out all the reports with a warrant i'm
gonna give it to you i'm gonna give you
your money's worth
a lot of times i stop here we go you get
a small bag of pot or something like
that we log it we give you a chewing
you're out you're gone our summons and
you're gone but if i have to dare to
warrant
i'll tell you you're going to jail and
i'm taking everything with you
so i think when we have something like
this bill in front of us we want to be
very very careful how we handle this
because we're opening a bucket of worms
for the cos and for everybody else and i
just say
things have been going rather good at
fish and game right now and i don't
think we should be upsetting the whole
bandwagon over a couple stories about
this one and that one and everything
else
and i just think we've got to use a
little common sense here not get excited
thank you very much chairman
so is that saying you you agree with the
not recommended for future legislation
yes sir thank you
further discussion with among the
committee
again i i do think some of this comes
down i call it boogeyman legislation
right we're afraid of something we're
not sure what we're afraid of right and
and that's kind of what this bill is is
that everyone has a story but no one
when you get down to the bases no one
can find the facts of the story in the
back end so it's not really there um so
i i don't like boogeyman legislation
somewhere might be afraid of but no one
ever no one's ever seen it and so that's
why i'll support uh
not recommended for future legislation
seeing no other testimony i recognize
representative smith for a motion
thank you mr chairman i'll make a motion
on hb 1091 to not recommend for future
legislation
one second i'm going to give
representative shirtless a chance
it's been moved far on a house bill 1091
uh the committee report direct to
reference it's not recommended for
future legislation
i will
i don't know if i have to do i have to
do a actual roll call vote can we do a
straw poll and because it's an interim
study report not a well it's going to go
to the floor
all right
great you just want me to do work
um all right so
seeing no further discussion will again
call the roll
uh representative khan
representative close
representative howard
representative craig
yes
representative love
represent wolf yes
representative kittridge yes
representative allard
yes
represent smith
yes representative harvey yes
represent horrigan
yes
representative massimilia yeah
representative querrey
oh he's in here
representative kenny
represent gallagher yes
represent shirtless yeah
the chair votes yes on a vote of 16 to
zero
i'll go on consent without objection
no objection
next we'll have the work session on
house bill 1201
relative to damage by bears
um again i'll summarize what i heard in
testimony was if we remember this bill
was just recently modified
in house bill 2
the trailer bill
in that in that modification one of the
conditions they set
was that in order for
members to get
future payments for bear damage to
property by bears
the fish and game would potentially
offer mitigation strategies to the
person who applied for the money the
first time and if they don't do those
mitigation strategies they could not get
a second year disbursement if they
didn't take care of the mitigation all
that being said i will say i think it
was last month colonel jordan i think
the rules finally went into place for
this so we don't even have what the
mitigation strategies would look like
what would potentially happen um so we
have absolutely zero data on on the on
on the changes we've already made
so i'm inclined to say not recommended
for future legislation again only
because we don't have any data to change
something that we just changed not a
year ago
and so that is my general summary of
what i heard and and my impression of
what i heard i'll open it up for colonel
jordan you want to add anything to that
or you guys okay
so still still waiting to be still
drafted but not presented to jail call
yet i'm assuming is that where we're at
maybe i'll see him this friday
um any other discussion on house bill
1201 fn relative damage by bears
representative wolf
did you say that the
law that went into effect as part of the
trailer bill limits you to recovery
two times
i i didn't no the changes i understand
it that was put into house bill 2 said
added a mitigation component saying that
instead of just saying every year you
could just apply and you just can apply
and that was the only condition if you
apply efficient game will assess whether
or not there are any mitigation
strategies that could be imposed that
would make it so it doesn't happen a
second time and if they recommend
mitigation strategies to a claimant
on this fund and the claimant chooses
not to implement the mitigation
strategies they probably won't get a
second payment because they didn't do it
fishing game asked them
it's two strikes and if you don't
mitigate
you're out correct that's basically
that's my understanding of the way the
rule the rule the
the new change was and the rules are
being worked on rules are currently
being worked on
seeing no further discussion i recognize
representative khan for the purpose of
emotion
i make a motion that
hb 1201
not to recommend for future legislation
it's been moved by representative khan
on house bill
1201 and it's seconded by
representative harvey
is there any further discussion on house
bill 1201
and the recommendation not direct not to
recommend for future legislation
not seeing any i will go to the vote
representative khan
representative close yes
representative howard
representative craig
yes
representative love yes
representative wolf yes
representative kittredge
yes
representative allard
yes representative smith yes
representative harvey yes
represent horrigan yes
represent massimilia
uh represent queries down here
representative
kenny
yes
represent gallagher
represent shirtless yes
ellis was in here oxless in here the
chair votes yes
on a vote of 16 to zero
uh the recommendation is for not
recommended for future legislation
without objectional going consent
i think that is our finishes all of our
work for the entire year
um representative khan had something he
wanted to bring to the committee
a few years ago uh while i was talking
to the new york fish and game commission
members i requested that if they can
have a meeting in seabrook because
our location in town and we have lots of
fishermen hunters it will be beneficial
that um our fishermen hunter can have
any question or concerns to bring to the
commission the commission agreed to have
a meeting on may 10th in cebu for their
next may meeting so we are inviting
anybody wants to come and you know
see the commission meeting and if they
have any concerns or questions and any
member or anybody of the public so i'm
inviting everybody
without any lobster though
represent wolf
where will that meeting be taking place
people town hall
uh one o'clock
so what was the date again
may 10th one o'clock
so may 10th 1a 1 pm sorry 1am that'd be
it that'd be an interesting meeting uh
1pm at the seabrook town hall will be
the next will be a fish and game
commission meeting anybody from the
seacoast who wants to attend is welcome
to attend
is there anything else
being done i want to say yes catherine i
i just would like since this seems to be
like our last time together i'd just
like to thank as a ranking member the
work of all of the committee members
this year on on the bills that we've
seen thank you
i
one other thing i just want to bring
over from the senate i attended a couple
of the hearings they passed the senate
passed unanimously one of our app the
ammo bill that cleaned up the language
around ammunition
the cam game cam bill is going to be
amended and i'll send an email out to
everybody once i get it back right now
it looks like fish and game is not in
favor of the i mean the senate's not in
favor of the 10-hour rule we put in or
the written recommendation they seem to
be okay with the labeling requirement
and senator bradley offered an amendment
that says if you put in a tree stand
you're going to take the tree stand out
by december 31st which i'm not generally
opposed to
um so we will have probably an email and
just about concurrence whether we'll
concur or not without with that change
that they do if if they move the bill
forward they may just kill it too so
um but other than that i think
they they passed the hike safe card um i
remember what the other one was it was a
fourth one
we sent it the squirrel bill has not
come together bill has not gone in front
of the committee yet
um yes representative craig
i just wanted to point out that i saw
the new rules for uh turkey season
and the issues we addressed on
410 and 28 gauge with heavy shot
required or now in place
thank you guys i appreciate that
anything else
um all right that being said thank you
all it's been a
joy being your chair for at least this
term we'll see what happens next year so
thank you have a great day
not recommended for future legislation
so i wrote down on my piece i put a nrfl